this i don't know it was like an acronym
i guess again
i think and it was like this british
dude obnoxious same thing
loud his girlfriend was really hot and
so they just do videos where he'd like
play fifa
and then she would like get get like
slowly take off pieces of clothing and
so now ricegum just does that that's his
new like genre of video
sick because like people click it it's
just like dude if you like well jerky
jerky time yeah yeah
yeah i love that you know i love a video
where
you know video games and boobs are
combined yeah dude
i'll watch those all [ __ ] day so good
or or
here's a wild thought porn oh just watch
porn
[Laughter]
it's way better it's way better it
doesn't have rice gum in it which is
automatically
yo rice gum in a porn would be the worst
just add
like something add him down in the
corner like he's
watching it on live stream and then you
know if you're that obsessed with
ricegum just do that but trust me it's
way better well you got like
you can actually see boobs in porn like
nipples and everything it's
nuts imagine how disappointed you would
be if some girl
in a porn is just you know yeah ooh and
the clothes come off
and then she bends over and then out of
the corners [ __ ] yo what is up guys
it's ricegum here
i'm gonna do my first porn today shit's
gonna be so crazy
so live i need to smash that like i need
you to smash that subscribe button
if we get this up to 200 000 likes i'm
gonna juice all over her [ __ ] feet
you know so let's get this going i got
the louis v on i got the [ __ ] [ __ ] on
you and you know what i'm saying
and you know what i'm saying i got the
homies in the back you know what i'm
saying we're gonna put this on the vlog
i'm finna [ __ ]
she's like i got the louis vuitton and
she's just covered and spit oh what is
up guys
here we got the gucci bag you know the
homies in the back we got the gucci man
purse son we got the necklace that's too
small that shit's almost a choker but
you know we got that gucci
i post videos bro on youtube the last
video i saw with him he's got like his
like the size of his hair cut and but
just the top is growing out
but he looks like a streamer girl named
kitty like
i can't take him seriously wait dude
speaking of streamer girls
that [ __ ] video you sent me of that
girl that admitted to killing the dog oh
yeah
[ __ ] i got some clothes
[Music]
all of my [ __ ] what